let's juxtapose the right thing with the
not right thing here's Sunny Hosten on
The View
I read a poll just yesterday that white
Republican Suburban women are now going
to vote Republican why it's almost like
roaches voting for raid right
now
Gilead okay so do we love it in the
hands do we love democracy or not
because just saying that it's insulting
to the voter people make up decisions on
what's right for their family and the
idea that well you should have a say for
everyone else's but the fact that women
are voting again you had a different
view on abortion not long ago
but that issue is right but then why but
then why is another woman
that white Republican Suburban women
you think you know
what anyone's interests are but your own
do you know that women man it doesn't
matter parents they've just had it you
people forced parents to feel that they
had to inject their kids with some [ __ ]
that they did not know what it was and
now rates in young men of myocarditis
are through the roof that is happening
for real so please Sunny Hosten do not
pretend you have anyone's interest in
mine other than the dingbats who have
hired you on that ridiculous show so
this is a stark contrast guys
the choice is yours right like the
choice is right now this is the moment
of choosing